hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
when we are looking at the emotion of
anger is it possible to divide it into
several different distinctive types so
this is the question that Thomas Aquinas
is considering in article 8 of question
46 of the somate logia Prima secundai
and there's a long background behind
this you see him mentioning a number of
names in this article beginning with you
know the philosopher Aristotle but he
also brings up you know Gregory the
great author of moralia on job Gregory
of Nissa John damaskeen Cicero there's a
number of different big thinkers out
there worried about anger and trying to
distinguish different types or species
with the word we get species from so how
do we in fact act divide it up and it's
it's very interesting I'll point out too
there's a little bit of trivia that
Thomas you know you can bet that he's
going to try his his hardest to
incorporate Aristotle Aristotle actually
distinguishes
four different kinds five if we count
the udamian ethics of anger Thomas is
going to read Aristotle as essentially
talking about three distinct kinds
because he's lumping two of them in
together so if we look at the initial
arguments as you know every article in
the summer begins with he says that it
seems that that John damaskeen has
incorrectly distinguished three types of
anger and we can translate these Latin
words in a lot of different ways
felmanium furorum right so we have
um
uh you know we could translate this as
wrath ill will and Rancor and what we're
going to see is that
the words aren't that important what
really is important is the function of
these different types and he says that
the members of a class are not
distinguished from each other on an
accidental basis right secundum oxidens
right but the three types are only
accidentally distinct the first reaction
of anger is called wrath enduring anger
anger that's permanence in the Latin is
called ill will Mania when it seeks an
opportunity for Revenge vindictum right
then it is Rancor and so the argument
here is well they're not really
distinctive types they're just
distinctive we could say maybe modes or
ways in which anger is manifesting
itself so that's one argument the next
one is is even more terminological right
and it's playing off of both Greek and
Latin so he's saying look Cicero and
John Damascus and are not actually on
the same page as we'd want them to be so
Cicero says that irascability is called
fumosis in Greek a kind of anger that
intermittently flares up and subsides
and this is in the course of the
tuscular and disputations where he's
discussing it right
John damaskeen however holds that
thumosis and Rancor are the same thing
therefore Rancor does not persist in its
search for Revenge but after a Time
dies down so this is kind of an issue as
as well right
where does this thumos or thumosis
actually fit in now we're getting more
terms thrown into the mix and then
finally here we get a different
threefold distinction this one is very
interesting right because Gregory the
Great in his moralia on job so this is a
commentary on Job in the moral sense
he's going to talk a lot about moral
matters and He suggests that there's
three degrees of anger
silent anger right you're um Cena vocha
that is anger without a voice
um
vocal anger Iran
and finally
outspoken or
um expressive anger
verbo espresso right so it's being quiet
but being angry saying something and
then actually saying something that
somebody's about to hear and and what
does he correlate this to well in the
sermon on the mountain Matthew
Jesus says uh you know there's three
different things that have to do with
anger if you're angry with your brother
then you're liable to the judgment and
then there's this if you say this word
raqqa to your brother if you call your
brother you fool then you know each one
is a little bit more serious so he says
whoever is angry with his brother this
is silent anger right and then whoever
shall say to his brother raqqa
indicating anger that's vocal but not
fully expressed right and then finally
whoever shall say thou fool which is a
complete statement so this doesn't line
up with John damaskeen's division of
anger and
Gregory would be proposing an alternate
so you know maybe we could have a fuller
account or maybe we have to correlate
these in some way so what does Thomas
say
Thomas says well you know they're all
kind of right in a way
um let's see if we can connect these
together he says the three types of
anger that John damaskeen and Gregory of
Nissa are talking about are based on
factors which intensify anger augmentum
right which which give an augmentation
to anger so how is anger augmented and
here Thomas says well let's think about
the way anger works you know we've got a
pain or sadness which is caused by some
sort of sliding some sort of wrong some
sort of Injustice against a person the
person gets angry right so there has to
be a reaction that crosses a certain
threshold and builds then there is
holding on to the anger he uses the term
remembering you know it's stuck in the
memory what's stuck in the memory not
just the feeling of anger but the pain
or the sadness and finally what anger is
looking for is Vengeance or Vindication
vindicacio and so that's that's the the
structure of this complex emotion and
Aquinas says well you can have an
intensification of anger in three
different ways you can have it here at
the getting angry you can have it here
at the remembering and you can have it
here at the Vengeance and each of these
changes the the kind of anger that we're
dealing with so he says the first is the
ease of the reaction right some people
get angry too quickly and this is called
uh wrath you know fell because it is
easily aroused now is there a good
lexical uh argument there I don't think
so but he's distinguishing it right so
some people are wrathful because they
get angry too easily you know they jump
to conclusions and stuff like that then
he says
in terms of the distress which you know
the sadness or pain which leads to anger
and is long remembered so the sadness or
pain is a feeling that results at a
moment and then you hold on to it for a
long time third on the part of the
object desired by the angry person
Vengeance right so
um you know the the second we call
ill will Mania or you could say holding
on to anger and then finally we have
furora right the word that we actually
get Fury from uh Rancor is is a good way
of Translating that the desire to
inflict revenge on the other person he
says this is a function of that which is
Never Satisfied until punishment has
been inflicted and then he brings in
Aristotle and he says Aristotle actually
talks about these three
types the Aristotle will actually call
these vices of anger we have the
choleric the akutos the people who get
angry too quickly the Hot Heads is
another great way of translating it or
quick tempered right and then others he
calls bitter amaros in Greek picros they
hold on to that feeling of being angry
and they won't be mollified made you
know soft uh for for a long time and
then finally the third type of the bad
temper the difficiles the halapoi in
Greek those who are literally kind of a
pain in the ass the The Grudge holders
the Vengeance Seekers
and um does this correlate perfectly to
Aristotle's discussions not exactly but
it's close enough right so this allows
us to answer the the first thing he says
any factor which contributes now it's
very interesting that he uses this word
Perfection and it's there right there in
the Latin he says uh Omnia illa
percocione a being brought to its
fulfillment we don't usually think about
perfect anger but we can talk about
anger running it's it's full course and
so he says any factor which contributes
to its Perfections more than accidental
it's it's actually kind of essential to
anger so we can distinguish according to
these factors then the second one he
says this harass ability through most or
thumosis
irascibility in in Latin and in English
seems to fit the first kind of anger
which is quo which is quick tempered
rather than rank are bought thumosis
which in thermos which in Latin becomes
fur May imply both quickness to anger
and firm intention to attain Revenge so
it kind of straddles the whole thing we
don't want to use this term in part
because it's a little bit too
loosey-goosey or ambiguous finally the
third one remember Gregory brought up an
entirely different classification
he points out something really important
just in the words that he's using
he's been asking about types species
what is Gregory bringing up he's not
bringing up types he's bringing up
degrees
grados of of anger right first you're
angry to this extent then you're angry
to this extent then you're angry too
this extent and all of that could be in
any of this stuff so he says these are
distinguished according to the effects
of anger and not
the degree of perfection uh known Autumn
Perfection of this angry reaction itself
so in a certain way the Gregory
classification is maybe less essential
than these three types that Thomas is
distinguishing so you see that he's able
to take in a lot of different you know
earlier perspectives on this this
complex emotion and bring them together
in a way that at least allows him a
plausible classification of the
different types of anger